economía en directo América de Franz 24
Jorge Hurtado ya con nosotros en el
estudio Jorge iniciamos nuestro
recorrido por la economía abordando la
huelga general que se produce en Francia
y además el impacto que tiene por
supuesto bueno en Europa es uno de los
temas más importantes y Es que luego de
tres semanas de bloqueos en refinerías y
depósitos ya hay casi un tercio de la
gasolineras en ese país que están siendo
afectadas los trabajadores que reclaman
un reajuste salarial por inflación y
mejores condiciones también se oponen a
la decisión del gobierno de obligar a
algunos empleados de las grandes
petroleras como total energym y Epson a
volver a suministrar la gasolina la
huelga se ha convertido en el mayor reto
del presidente Emmanuel macron desde su
reelección en mayo pasado el portavoz
del gobierno Olivier verán dijo que la
requisición o este llamado obligatorio
además personal para las refinerías
podría producirse durante el día según
un comunicado de Epson sus refinerías
podrían tardar entre dos y tres semanas
en volver a funcionar por completo tras
las la protesta está afectando todos los
sectores económicos desde el transporte
hasta las centrales nucleares vamos a
los números y Raúl hasta el momento hay
afectaciones en el 50% del tráfico de
trenes regionales específicamente se ha
afectado también el 10% a los de los
profesores de secundaria que se fueron a
huelga y un 30% de estaciones de
combustible y un y una encuesta dice que
el 39% de los ciudadanos apoyan las
huelgas mientras que otro 49%
se ponen a ella y 39 Las apoyan claro
Jorge cambiamos ahora información y le
preguntó cómo reaccionaron los mercados
a los cambios en la política fiscal de
Reino Unido no que lo vimos ayer Bueno
los principales índices bursátiles de
Reino Unido alcanzaron Este martes sus
niveles más altos en más de una semana
la histórica revocación de los planes de
recortes de impuestos sin financiación
del gobierno y el optimismo sobre la
temporada de beneficios disparó incluso
las estadounidenses durante la noche el
índice
ftsc 100 subió un 0,9% alcanzando su
nivel más alto desde el 10 de octubre y
el ftse 250 de ámbito nacional subió un
1% su nivel no visto desde el 5 de
octubre el nuevo ministro de economía
británico Jeremy home descartó el plan
económico de la primera ministra list
Trust y redujo su plan de apoyo a la
energía revirtiendo la pérdida de
confianza que habían ocasionado este
plan cambiamos otra vez ese tema Jorge
porque australi Singapur firmaron un
acuerdo de economía verde le pregunto de
qué se trata este acuerdo bueno esta
iniciativa Busca impulsar la cooperación
en materia de inversiones financiación y
tecnología todo relacionado con el clima
por ejemplo Las Naciones esperan crear
una lista de bienes y servicios
medioambientales que podrían recibir un
trato comercial preferencial el Primer
Ministro australiano australiano Anthony
albanis mencionó el proyecto Sun cable
que exporta energía hablar desde el
norte de Australia a Singapur a través
de Indonesia el acuerdo tiene 17
componentes que van desde facilitar el
comercio y la inversión en servicios
verdes la armonización de normas y la
creación de sectores de crecimiento
verde con el apoyo del sector privado
Australia busque reducir sus emisiones a
cero en 2050 y Singapur está
considerando también adoptar este mismo
objetivo escuche música de 100
el acuerdo de economía verde entre
Singapur y Australia que apoyará la
transición de nuestros países hacia las
emisiones netas 0 y al mismo tiempo
impulsará el crecimiento y creará
puestos de trabajo en los sectores
verdes es el primer acuerdo de este tipo
entre países y Esperamos que sirva de
guía para que otros países de forma
similar cooperen entre sí para hacer
frente a lo que es un problema global
de Australia nos vamos a Estados Unidos
Jorge porque el gobierno yo bailén
buscaría la liberación de más reservas
de petróleo estamos hablando de Entre 10
a 15 millones de barriles de petróleo de
las reservas de la nación esto para
intentar estabilizar los precios del
mercado que por el tema de la inflación
esclavos súper altos según Bloom para la
casa blanca Busca evitar que los precios
de la gasolina continúen al alza esta
Liberación haría parte del último bloque
de un programa de 180 millones de
barriles que comenzó en la primavera
también se espera esta semana que el
gobierno brinde detalles sobre los
planes para reponer las reservas de
emergencia porque ya ha habido
anteriores es importante señalar que las
anteriores liberaciones de las reservas
de petróleo en Estados Unidos no han
impactado en el precio del mercado que
más bien seguía por los anuncios de los
países productores de la OPEP sobre la
producción petrolera el aumento en los
precios de la gasolina es la principal
preocupación del presidente Joe biden
que en las últimas semanas advirtió
inclusive a las compañías petroleras a
que no suban Los costos bueno y volvemos
a cambiar de información porque ecson ya
oficializa su salida de Rusia y cataloga
la operación como una expropiación Bueno
una semana después de que inició la
Guerra en Ucrania la empresa anunció su
intención de abandonar Rusia y comenzó
una reducción paulatina de la
cooperación pero en agosto pasado Epson
envió un aviso de diferencia a las
autoridades rusas luego de que el
kremlin bloqueara la salida del gigante
petrolero sajalín 1 este fue el primer
paso para establecer una demanda contra
Rusia un portavoz de la empresa dijo que
Rusia había terminado con sus intereses
A través de dos decretos y la operación
a una empresa rusa y como lo estábamos
adelantando en esta ronda informativa
porque tras la cancelación en el 2020 la
restricciones de Kobe 19 Volvió el salón
del automóvil en París Bueno ya está
edición trae especial atención sobre los
vehículos eléctricos así como a las
empresas francesas y chinas que están
exponiendo Bruno van en el director del
producto de la marca Renault come
comentó que casi uno de cada dos
clientes se está pasando a comprar ya
vehículos eléctricos Qué te parece Bueno
me parece excelente Pues en la medida de
lo posible no de las posibilidades de
cada quien puedes hacer esa transición a
una energía más limpia Jorge como
siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información más adelante más economía
pasamos a saludar ahumares a que tiene
toda la información de los deportes
[Música]